all I did was say maybe this meteor came
from outside the solar system based on
the government data I respected the data
from the US government because the U.S
space command is the organization paid
more than NASA to figure out if there
are any national security threats and if
they were wrong by a factor of three in
the case of this Fireball then I would
never sleep at night because I would say
tens of billions of dollars are
allocated to an organization that
advises President Biden about ballistic
missiles I would say that's what they're
saying in the scientific paper in the
astrophysical journal a couple of months
ago that's exactly what they were saying
that the U.S space command doesn't know
what they are talking about